Kids
and that doesn't necessarily sound very
important.
They're just
really,
again,
is actually a microcosm of world just
like any play.
Normally
the microcosm of normals are capitalism
and say you've been learning people
about like playing because even though
it's the board is real,
people with real emotions that will be
relevant in real
until you can see what their funding,
if they're funding play in
winning,
he attributes
it detached themselves from a little bit
so that it's easy.
Hey,
remember that it's like the
sophisticated things.
It's fundamental a rate by testing to
play with your testing,
how well they match was and so that's
what kids do.
Play Games with their friends too.
It's more complicated because those
games,
especially if they're pretending.
So let's say kids freaking excited,
going to play house.
This is a common kits and pavement first
thing that it was negotiation,
so screenwriters and say,
will you be the mom that you need the
data?
You know,
you can be the cat and then if everyone
wants to play that role,
but that's the first thing the kids
have.
All the kids have to one play
voluntarily or not,
so that's a good thing to keep in mind.
Everybody accepts the goal and then you
might say,
well then they go and imitate the mother
and the father and the cap,
but they don't actually imitate them
because like if I was entertaining,
you would move exactly the same way you
will,
but if I was caricatured review,
let's say I got to know you a little
bit,
then I can kind of adopt the spirit of
your voice and your mannerisms.
Whatever they are,
I could extract from you a pattern of
church artist doing.
I could avoid that pattern on some long
more sophisticated interest invitation
and that's what the kids are trying to
do when they play house and I'm
indicating their father because they
weren't doing exactly the same movements
that the father was doing.
They've watched the quad that need the
father over multiple contexts and
they've extracted on the commonalities
across those contexts and portrayed that
with the term terms.
You can think about that as a spirit.
It's the spirit of that being the
partner across multiple contexts and
then they're acting that representing a
play and so they can say what they're
doing and they can't tell them what the
rules are,
but they can use their own body to
represent this incredibly complex thing
that they don't understand and they
could do the same thing with mother.
They can play with a goal and feed it
and do all those things,
but the mother doesn't can practice
being a mother,
so they learn how to do this ideal.
Describe it.
There's a lot of things that we knew
like that and so we know how to act out
things that you don't understand it now.
Eventually we figured out collectively
over the 10 years you've been trying to
figure things out,
how to act in a manner that makes us
essentially civilized,
civilized.
That enables us to sit in this group
even though we don't know each other and
to all the same thing,
to all the same posture and to all about
essentially the same attitude,
Nsap,
emotional state,
and to thereby being predictable to one
another and to be safe with one,
which is what we're doing right now.
It's a ritual.
Everyone understands it's a theatrical
Richard that everyone understands and
the fact that everyone is doing the same
thing means that we can all be virtually
assured that at the moment we're all
holding the same ideal and that's why
we're not terrified because if someone,
all of a sudden I stood up and branch to
90 nineties,
this was not be the same place.
Right?
It was seriously,
you don't want the same place and you
wouldn't be using the same part of your
brain to process.
It would switch instantly and you'd be
possessed by ancient motivational
states,
terror and rage and the preparation for
action.
That would be completely outside of the
neurological systems that you're using
to orient yourself at this moment and
people do not like it.
When that happens.
We don't like even if someone,
you know what that's like,
if you're walking down the street and
you see someone who's doing something
that isn't normal,
like maybe they're muttering to
themselves preaching a little bit or
something like that and they're a little
disheveled,
you'll do what almost everyone does,
which is we'll give them a wide berth
and you'll keep on walking and you
probably do what you can not to make eye
contact because that's an invitation,
so you're,
you're.
You walk down the street and you think,
oh,
there's some unexplored territory
circumvented that,
and then you continue on so everything
you can as a consequence of your options
to stop yourself from being exposed to
anything that disrupts the stability of
the theory that you're using to
orientate yourself in the world.
That's why people hold onto their
theories because underneath that is like
terror rage and you don't want that
coming up and so we don't take it
kindly.
People come along and masks are the
axioms of our theories.
We seriously look like that and that's
partly why people are so motivated to
protect their belief systems.
Right?
It's not only that we construe the world
with our belief systems,
we organize our social behavior,
we started building systems,
and so if you mess with the belief
systems,
you mess with the structure that makes
everyone predictable to everyone else.
And that is not.
There's nothing been down that path,
that's for sure.
Alright,
so now
we've learned how to act out this
pattern.
It makes us acceptable and desirable
project and we're constantly reminding
each other how to do that because like
if you go to a party,
you're gonna want people who knows when
you walk by.
If you're the typical person,
a typical reasonably well socialized
person,
you're going to want people to like you
more than they dislike what you're going
to want to pay some attention to you.
You're going to want to engage people in
interesting conversation.
Maybe you're going to want people to
appreciate you and you know if you want
to have a good time to have a good time
party needs to act in a certain way that
elicits a certain set of responses from
other people.
And if you fail it,
that they will tell you,
they'll ignore you,
they won't laugh at your jokes,
you know they'll move away from you.
There's all sorts of reasons.
There's all sorts of things they will do
to broadcast at you,
your deviation from the ideal.
And that can be very painful,
right?
Especially if you're very deviant from
the ideal because it opens up this
realization that you just don't know
what they hell you're doing at all,
and that either means that other people
are contemptible and horrible and
something should be done about that or
that there's something seriously wrong
with you that needs to be rectified.
And neither of those options are very
pleasant.
So we carry within us,
let's say,
implicit ideal that we carry within us.
A counter idea as well.
The opposite of that.
That's an introduction in some sense to
the landscape of good and evil because
the ultimate ideal is whatever is good,
that the ultimate counter ideal is
whatever's evil.
So that's the space within which we map
our behaviors and we can't help but map
out that space because it's.
It constitutes the most extreme version
of this structure that we use to
evaluate everything everyone else does
in everything we do.
We also know that that's the case
because when you go to a movie,
even though you don't know that you know
it's the case,
you go to a movie,
let's say it's an action group or it
doesn't matter.
It could be a roadmap.
Maybe those are the two basic categories
of foods.
Naturally he has a hero if you're is
either greg or partially do like a
complex here,
but in kind of a flawed and interesting
way.
Right?
And then of course in an action movie,
there's the evil bad guy as well,
but hopefully he's not good enough
because otherwise it's a caricatures,
but always into movies.
You have that hero and the villain and
the intermodal maxwell that you have the
person who's the love interest in all
those who've failed to measure up.
And so it's the same thing.
It's just played out for different
reasons.
So you know it's,
it's difficult to understand that if you
go to see your movie,
which is fiction,
isn't real,
then it's also more real than real
because otherwise you either watching
it,
you don't want the movie director to
show you how many times the protagonists
links before they get out of bed in the
morning.
It's not interesting when you want them
to do is to take the full panoply of
here with behavior and only extract from
it those instances that are particular
interest in relationship to the
portrayal of that ideal or the counter
id.
You want to see why they're bad guys bad
and you want to see why the group guys
good and that's more real than reality
because it's abstracted from reality.
It's more real than reality.
Like numbers are more real than the
things that are derived from some form
of abstraction.
Right?
And it doesn't.
It makes perfect sense that when you
want to extract from fictional
representations,
there's represent representations of
what's good and what's evil,
so that in principle,
assuming that this is what you want,
you could do a better job of embodying
what's good because then everything
would go well for you in the world
world,
assuming that that's what you want,
so there's probably nothing more
important than you could possibly do
that.
No do that,
and that's why you treat it like it's
more important than anything else.
You can do this.
If you think about it,
you will go to a movie and you'll line
up and you pay to be exposed to that
kind of information and that's an.
That's an indication of exactly how it
is,
right?
You actually find most of you,
and if it isn't movies slogan,
it's it's fiction or or stories that
people tell you,
no interest whatsoever in people and
that's very rare.
If even if that's the case,
you'll find that science fiction or
something else like that where the
mythology creeps into the technology
doesn't really matter.
It's going to come at you one way or
another and the fact that you will pay
to expose yourself to that and then also
that when you go into those venues,
be entranced by it despite yourself,
despite the fact that you know,
is real,
is an indication of exactly how
important that information is.